and our burglary is a bad issue of
course happens every 40 seconds here in
the uk apparently so home security big
market and there's very expensive to go
and buy all these fancy cameras and have
them all rigged up uh if you look at any
sort of hardware shops it does cost a
fortune so how about a tech alternative
which is an app and is free it's called
manything and james west is the ceo he's
here good to see you and this is
pretty phenomenal for free james tell us
how it works
so you download the app to your iphone
in fact i've got one here running in
fact on your desk
that's my old iphone so i've got my
upgrade here and
run the old run the app on my old phone
and it streams video live to our servers
where you can watch it remotely either
from your desktop or from the phone you
carry around with you so let you see
live and it will send you alerts if
anything moves and you can get right to
the bit of video of interest so it's
um it is like the the cheap option if
you come out
actually looked at some cameras and
things myself they are expensive to set
up with the hard drives to buy and all
the rest of it this is ultimately
the free version songs you don't want to
look at information for too long
you can look at the information as long
as you like it's actually a very
sophisticated system because the
device you're running the app on is got
a great camera and got a great computer
on it so
it's all the sophistication of a
high-end system
uh that you can get going in seconds but
what about storing information if you
want to go back and look at a scene from
six months ago is that possible yeah you
can store it all in the cloud and we're
going to charge people who need to keep
a lot of video online but our free users
can get up to 12 hours of watch back
time for
nothing and then from sort of 2.99 a
month and up you can start to keep it
for longer so you can look back weeks
months if you if you like
what about any sort of regulation on
this
when you've got something as portable as
a phone
there's the sort of
snooper element to it isn't that you
could potentially do something you
shouldn't do with this yes i mean you've
got to operate within the law and
cameras have been around a long time and
so people are quite used to what they're
allowed and not allowed to do uh mostly
you can't make people operate within the
law they can you once the technology is
out there and the facility is there
you've got no say on what people do with
it no put it in your neighbor's house
well yes but if
you'll see you think about it
you can break the law if you like but
you're going to get in trouble i mean
most of our users are using it for very
innocent things like watching their pets
when they're at work or watching their
home when they're away that's the sort
of typical use i mean roughly half our
users are using it for dogs which was a
surprise to us but
that's the main
mostly innocent what about we talk about
obviously security in the home what
about security as far as hacking into
that feed because obviously they're
logging onto a website to watch their
own feed yeah is that secure yes great
question actually because you will have
seen in the news recently uh stories
about webcams getting hacked and that
was because these cameras are being sold
that you buy off the shelf with default
passwords on them we're actually running
our software and one of the most secure
operating systems in the world which is
ios
and we hold all the video in the cloud
it's encrypted and the user's passwords
are encrypted so we think it's very
secure
brilliant love it it's i have to say i
i've as i look straight into the camera
there you go hello it's i mean it's it's
a great application but
technology that we've all got yeah which
is i mean the thing is when we started
two and a half years ago not many people
have spare iphones lying around you roll
on two and a half years there are
millions we think there are over 300
million spare unused devices sitting in
people's drawers and uh that's just
going to keep on happening
brilliant lovely john great to talk to
james rather great to talk to you thank
you very much indeed